[Music]
for two years Donald Trump jr. has lived
at the very heart of the Russia story
which we now know was a conspiracy
theory for attending a meeting with a
Russian lawyer nobody's ever heard of he
has been accused of betraying his
country many suggested he would die in
prison we now know that none of that was
real they were lying or they were being
hysterical either way it was not true it
looks like he's not going to prison
Donald Trump jr. instead joins us
tonight
don't Trump thanks very much for coming
on so I can't recall the number of times
I heard people predict that you would be
indicted you have not been indicted
you're not gonna be indicted not but
it's thousands if not much more than
that Tucker so what's the experience
like what's it like to be you right now
listen it feels great I mean because I
was a big part of all of this going on
I'm the one that took the daily incoming
of the nonsense now at the same time I'm
also the person that was actually there
that was actually in the room so I
understand everything that went into it
I realized we didn't do anything wrong
certainly when you look at what the
other side was doing you realized that
it was them in fact colluding not us we
were doing the campaign we were
functioning like any campaign would and
that's what we did so it was difficult
to watch it was difficult to watch what
they're trying to and have been trying
to do to my father for two years and
it's really the Democrats with their
media lackeys creating a narrative that
they want to be true because they
couldn't explain the outcome of the last
election my father won he was able to
speak to the American people he's been
able to move the needle for them in a
way that Barack Obama couldn't come
close to doing but by the way it's not
just a partisan issue
Bush couldn't have done it either my
father has done incredible things he's
done things for working-class Americans
you have all-time low african-american
unemployment all-time low Hispanic
unemployment all-time low female
unemployment and he's doing that with
this bubble around him for two years
think of what he could do without that
noise so I what I never understood is
why not if you don't agree with the
policies of the administration
raishin or the campaign before it on
trade or immigration pick a topic why
not debate them the Russia story seemed
to subsume all of that no one was
talking about the details of any policy
some policies weren't even being
affected as a result of it
weren't getting done why not have like a
conventional political debate because
the Democrats can't win with their ideas
with the issues and the things that they
want to push they don't work
we tried that under Obama they're trying
that with the green New Deal the only
problem is we don't exactly have 93
trillion dollars to spend to say you're
gonna take a bus to Hawaii that doesn't
work their ideas do not work and they
recognize that so the way to try to
combat that is to demonize a guy who's
getting it done
with ideas that they can't stand and
that's what my father's been doing
Tucker but this wasn't in the day out
the Russia story wasn't simply about
your father who was about the people
around him very much including you I
mean you were a major figure in this
narrative as they say because I was the
needle in the haystack Tucker we handed
over our emails I did 27 something hours
of testimony in front of congressional
committees and you know what happens you
go in the meeting at the end of seven
our testimony guys do you have any more
questions ask him go look at the records
do you have any more questions no we
have none
guys like donning dick Blumenthal go
outside on the steps of Congress 30
seconds later hold a press conference
saying there are many questions that
were not answered
it's nonsense Tucker it's all a game and
you got the leader of the tinfoil hat
brigade Adam Schiff out there every day
talking about the evidence of collusion
that he's seen he's flagrantly lying to
the American people he's doing it every
day on national television he's gotten
more airtime amazingly enough than
Michael avenatti but they're about of
the same level of credibility and
there's no accountability for that
Tucker because when you're on that side
and you have the media carrying your
water for you you can say whatever you
want when you're on our side even when
you're right even when you're proven so
there's a level of Copa
ability there are repercussions for
being a conservative that you don't face
if you're on the other side so one of
those repercussions been like for you I
mean how is that since there are
millions of people who believe that you
are a Russian agent or abetting other
Russian agents the most serious charge
of you level against anybody betraying
your country well how is that affected I
mean what's the like when you go to the
grocery store well listen in New York
City it's a little bit different than
the rest of the country obviously uh you
know the reality is this I'm a patriot
true and true I love this country I love
everything that it stands for and the
difference between me amazingly enough
as the son of a billionaire from New
York City is that unlike the Democrats I
actually spend a lot of time in middle
America whether it be my hobbies and the
outdoors or shooting and fishing I know
those people guess how many of them have
even asked about Russia zero because
they know that it's nonsense and this is
the media's classic move they take the
narrative that they understand in their
little New York and DC bubbles and they
try to sell that to the rest of the
country but the rest of the country gets
it you know what they see they see
manufacturing jobs coming back to this
country they see their wages rising for
the first time in decades they see the
stock market in their 401ks at all-time
highs they see all-time low unemployment
what is the Democratic platform is do
the opposite of anything that Donald
Trump has done if Donald Trump came out
today in favor of oxigen the Left would
be against it do they really want to
reverse the successes that we have seen
do they really want to reverse all-time
low unemployment numbers for all the
minorities listed what was that
conversation I mean can we begin the
conversation about policy now and what
happens since I mean presumably at some
point they're gonna acknowledge reality
which is Muller cleared the
administration of collusion charges so I
doubt they ever do that because it's not
their style and again there's no
accountability on their side that's so
there's two things that have to happen I
think we have to look into how this all
started okay this didn't start with some
FBI agent a door kicker this started
with the lawyer bureaucrats at the top
of the FBI working with Hillary Clinton
Fusion GPS Christopher Steele Peter
struck the
people need to be looked into this is
the greatest farce ever perpetrated on
our democracy it's a disgrace and it's a
stain on our Constitution we have to fix
that then what I'd like I'd like us all
to get together let's start working how
about we pass some bills for
infrastructure why don't the Democrats
get together with the Republicans and my
father and actually start doing and
continuing the amazing things that my
father has been doing for the American
people that's what I'd like to say yeah
I'd like to see that kind of unity I'd
like to see the Democrats focusing on
what's good for the American people
right not just screaming on TV trying to
perpetuate a hoax and a myth that they's
themselves have created because the
media and the Democrats have no
credibility right now the atom shifts of
the world have no credibility right now
and it's going to take years for them to
gain that back if they don't try to
actually do something to effectuate
change and to get things moving for the
American people again my father did
amazing things with all of this stuff
going on with this cloud over his head
imagine what he could do if you let him
do his thing they may want to sit this
one out maybe jump on the Trump train
let's get this thing going and let's
keep the winning because we can do it
look at what's going on maybe they'll
wake up and realize well see Don Trump
jr. thanks very much for that Thank You
Tucker